thank you for coming to pi data global
2021
and uh i will
i get like sorry if i mispronounce your
name ding qin uh
i also go by sarah
all right
uh senator is an economics phd candidate
candidate at american university her
research interests are corporate finance
behavioral finance and macroeconomics
besides being a ph candidate
she's an adjunct instructor teaching
economics and business
financial economics economics and in
machine learning and natural language
processing enthusiast enthusiast and
since this third time i'll go ahead and
pass the mic off
you can go ahead and take over
thank you stephen for hosting this and
it's my great pleasure to be here and
share my work
so this i changed the title a little bit
because this paper is one of my
dissertation and it's still a very
ongoing project i'm just sharing part of
the work here with you and i will focus
on how i deal with the text data and how
i transform text data into economic
research so it might be a little bit
different
other speakers
presentation this one is intern
displaying
talk because it's trying to combine data
science and economic together
so as you can see here um the paper i
focus on manager attention and
firm's
financial decision here i focus on the
leverage dynamics i would like to start
with my motivation so here you might
want to ask why does manager's attention
matter in their financing decision the
answer is the limited attention or
restrictions to human attention is
everywhere in our life
thinking about back in the early 21
century and 2020 we have this bloom of
information technology and therefore we
have access to tv to computer lab to
internet to our phone and here from
there we uh open up the window to a lot
of information and you might can feel
this in your daily life that not only
you are struggling to try to have a work
life balance but also you're trying to
allocate your time or your attention to
different texts you're focusing on so
it's very challenging critical issue for
every individual
and surely
for
professional
managers they are also facing with this
challenge
but however in our traditional economic
theory
they assume that everyone is rational
and they will pay full attention to
everything or they can afford a resource
to have access to all the attention
in theory a lot of
scholars they try to estimate
actually how much attention we pay to a
certain target for example if i am a
housewife i might want to
pay attention to the grocery price but i
actually don't pay attention to that all
the time because i allow this range of
price fluctuation therefore if i have to
give you a number an agent will pay
attention to the target only half of the
time
and let's turn back to the the firms the
managers a real life issue so as a
manager
why why i'm trying to making a decision
for the best financial choice for my
company i am actually exposed to many
different information many different
challenges for example i might face with
for example establishment establishment
issues or the project i'm working on but
however i'm also very vulnerable to the
very common shocks for example the
pandemic or earthquake or just financial
crisis i have no control of that
therefore in order to
in response to those shocks i will have
to
probably pay a few attention to it but
there is a very critical difference
during the economic cycle i'm going to
show you in a later um a little bit
introduction to the current research
about attention um
we eco economy economists start to pay
attention to um
we start to have a concern of managerial
attention
um maybe 10 years ago
but we only have success to doing this
recently because attention is very
abstract concept it's not like price or
gdp you can you can easily quantify it
um therefore so far the measures of
attention is very limited people like
for example um those two papers here the
first two paper here um they want to
study inflation versus unit price
inflation we see it as a macro factor
because everyone is
affected by that however unit price is
only seen as a company's managers
those two
represented papers they show in their
paper that in
between inflation and unit price
managers pay more attention to
unit price they are more focused on
their firm specific issues instead of
focusing on the general inflation
and another field is called investor
attention because as investors even
though i'm just investing to individual
firms stock
this company can also be affected by
common macro
shocks or just by their firm specific
issues
um so therefore there are a lot of
papers talk actually a lot of people
talking about investor attention i just
listened to here
and there's research in managerial
financial decision i mean how well
manager's attention affect their
financing decision is very very absent
so far i only find one paper that's
focused on its issue um this paper here
they're discussing the very interesting
um
more it's actually more specific than i
discussed here they focus on every
manager's background and then study
whether their manager's style and
intention is different from
given they have different background so
let me um this is the motivation part
let me push it further because we want
to focus on the data set here
another
reason that i want to focus on the
financing decision is that we
over the past 20 years we observe a
heightened or skyrocketed leverage ratio
um in theory we think the leverage ratio
or were the firm's the or the firm's
optimal level ratio shouldn't be very um
differentiated over the time but however
recently there's a concern of this
heightened leverage ratio and we cannot
explain
why the level ratio start keep going to
a further high level and i hope my um
my theory of attention
can help answer this question
i will skip this part to
being faster with my data part so what i
do this paper
is firstly i generate a very novel
measurement of manager attention i look
at manager attention from two
perspectives the first one is attention
capacity the attention capacity is
defined as units of information paying
to the target so here we i look at the
individual managers attention and their
attention uh capacity equals to two
parts i will introduce later
um and using the text data is really
provides it's really opened a new window
to the measurement of attention because
traditionally they use either survey
data or they just look at the
professional forecasters whether they
will adjust their forecasting if this
forecaster adjusts their focusing it
means they're definitely paying
attention but however when a focus not
adjusting
his um the the number
currently
this action is seen as not paying
attention but we know that's definitely
not true so there are limitations for
other measures and also they don't have
this um
[Music]
we cannot objectively measure it and
keep updating
um but i can overcome this difficulty
with using text data
and the second one is more econ part
after having my measure i use this
measurement into my economic studies
so there are briefly there are two
findings the first one is manager
attention capacity is variant because
this one is very important finding
because in cast economic research we all
assume
managers attention is constant therefore
they can only focus on either
the the the past research only focus on
the allocation part but here i found the
tension capacity is variant that will
change the whole story of how the system
is going on and the second one is the
managerial information friction is
featured by limited attention and this
can amplify the role of business cycle
on manager of financial decision
and also for the first part i want to
briefly mention here is that
paying attention to macroeconomic
companies with attention capacity
expansion and as a result it lowers the
manager's estimation where it's
uncertainty about future status
therefore when a manager is more
confident of knowing about the future
status it can result in higher leverage
ratio
because it can it can afford to take the
risk however
assume that the firm for specific
volatilities or sperm specific
challenges are not changing paying more
attention to macroeconomics can distract
the managers from focusing on the firm
specific issues and therefore
their estimation precision about future
firm status will decrease therefore as a
result
it will lower the leverage ratio
so how do i start and what materials i
use so i use tax data specifically i use
the public
the public listed firms quarterly
earnings call transcript and the data
frame is from the quarter 1 2004 to
quarter 3 2020 and the source is fact
set
why do i use this text data is there any
other text results of course
traditionally people also like to use
for example news
news articles or they like to use the
report to sec the security um regulation
institution but
that's what this document is what we
call 10k or 10q 10q is also published
quarterly however there are
one critical question that those two
alternative tax data cannot overcome
first one when we're trying to measure
the attention we want to ask whose
attention but however if we're thinking
about newspaper articles
who are writing those articles is the
journalist if we're using the news
articles were measuring new journalist
attention instead of the manager's
detention and thinking about the 10 q
10k reported to the regulator
those are basically written by firstly
they are written by public lawyers and
secondly if i i have did research and
look into every
quarter's
the thank you documents for for example
apple actually it doesn't change much
over
maybe two years or three years so it's
not very informative to reflect what the
managers are really thinking
comparatively this earnings call
transcript is based on the quarterly
earnings call under the regulation
all the publicist companies they will
need to have or host this conference
every quarter to exchange their
perspective about their company or the
perspective of the future economic
status with the investors and what's
more during this conference called some
of the institutional investors they can
be invited to ask questions they join
the q and a session
therefore
the managers are sort of forced to
exchange the real idea of what they're
thinking
and if you have a chance to look at some
ernie's call transcript you can see that
um
the parties from the firm or the
managers from the firm who join into
those conferences they are the c-suite
managers the ceo cfo as i highlighted
with the red line here and
and from here you can see what they
cover in this transcript they are very
far looking and they study for example
the revenues gross margin operation
expenses and capital allocation and more
importantly this one is from apple um
2021 q2 transcript and you can see it's
still talking about code 19. so there
are two things when we select the text
say the first one
for my study first one whose attention
and second one what they are focusing on
what they are talking to
and
clearly here the example i have here
simply reflect what they are talking to
they are really focused on the financing
issues and they also reflect their
perspective towards both firm specific
and macro
macroeconomic focus events so therefore
that's
this is the the proof that this is a
very nice tax resources for us or for me
to generate my attention measurement and
how do i do it
well the
approach that i had is not anything too
innovative or it's not anything that's
super complicated
i use a very traditional natural
language processing technique which is
called term frequency inverted document
frequency here after i will use the term
tf idf to refer to this method
so i you the the way
that this measurement used is very
simple firstly
for a given article in my case a given
earnings call transcripts document it
counts every words frequency
and the second we want to give every
word a weight which is how important is
reflected among all of our
earnings called transcripts and this
method is it's not anything new it's
being
a fundamental part of financial language
processing for a long while and also
it's being widely used in economic
research
and as usual when we want to deal with
text data not every text they are the
same we know when we say things when we
write things things
aside from using very informative words
for example macro firm
revenues price margins we can also use
words like and off or however those
words that i just said uh the second
part they are not very informative so
therefore we call it stop words when we
are doing the text analysis we want to
get rid of those not very informative
words so therefore when we when i have
my underscore transcript the first step
is to
split the whole article into each
individual words and after that i
toss all of the not very informative
words or and however things like that
and
and another thing is
for a simple words who share the same
root for example finance or financing
financial they all share the same root f
i n a
and c
um if i treat them differently that my
underestimate the frequency of the same
idea therefore we use the
um the technique word stemming to filter
out
to treat every word therefore we will
have well i will end up having the same
words with the same root
so that's the first step which
i uh noted as the omega here the omega
represents for each term and
specifically the terms by after the stem
or
get rid of a stopwatch and the second
one
for each individual earnings called
transcript documents is consists of a
vector of omega and f here i noted for
firm f that's for each individual firm
at the quarter t because i have
for each individual form i have a unique
transcript for each quarter for very
long time
and i use the lower letter d ft to refer
to each individual earnings called
transcript document and i use the
capital d as the set a set of all and
it's called transcript documents and
this is how i calculate my tf and idf
for example t f which is consists of my
omega d and my document
lower letter d
it's basically very simple counting and
calculation on the numerator i have the
count of the words um were a specific
words for example finance or f i n
a and c on the numerator and on the
denominator i just count the total
number of terms in that document d and
for the
here this d f w d
maybe i need a pen here
for this one
that's the measurement to give every
term a weight in order to calculate this
df i have the
n omega capital d here and this one
refers to the number of document d that
contains the term w in the document set
capital d
and idf you just take a log and in of
the inverted df so the log we know just
a scale for the for the purpose of
scaling and one over df will make will
give the weight of the term omega
and tf.idf is simply just utf times this
idf
so the calculation is very
straightforward and very simple anymore
anyone can follow this
method
to make it more straightforward to you
i show you a table here to represent
how do i really calculate it
so the step of using the cf idf is that
in order to give every term a weight i
want to figure out
what terms are related to macro issues
and what terms are related to the firm
specific issues
so um
but to look at into the detail how i
calculate that for example we have the
term
gdp in the earnings call transcript and
i count the term frequency for the gdp
and also here in my example i also have
other three words first one is the
monetary second one is the use and third
one handicraft and you can basically
tell that
for our knowledge gdp and monetary they
are related to macro issues and use is
the very common word we use it uh all
the time and handicraft is just very
uncommon
that we're barely seeing in our
writing
so here
by looking at the term frequency we can
see that gdp are mentioned many many
times and comes
right come after that monetary and the
use
and tf remember we just
use the term frequency over the total
number of words in this document so that
that that is to say all the gdp monetary
use used in handicraft they are going to
use the same denominator because they
they are in the same documents so after
doing that process tf we have a number
like this so you can see this number is
very
correlated with the raw term frequency
and after that we calculate document
frequency which means
here gdp has this number
it's a relatively big number which means
that gdp appears the term gdp appears in
11
952 earnings called transcript and
that's really the big number to
calculate idf we do one over this number
and then take a lot and that's how we
have the idf and we do the same thing to
all the other three words and tf idf is
simply t f times
idf
and you can see
some interesting scales is happening
here
tf is counting the frequency idf is
giving a weight and tfidf is counted the
weighted
tf of the weighted term frequency and
you can see that in order to have a high
tf idf we want to have a high tf and
also a high idf here i want to draw your
attention to gdpn the use
both gdp and the use have a relative
high tf but however use the term use
appear in so many um documents so that's
in the natural focus natural language
processing we see the use as not very
informative therefore the idf is very
low therefore despite we have a
relatively high value of
0.003 the overall tf idea of the score
is a much smaller number compared to
monetary because you can see tf
monitoring usually have the same number
but for idf
monetary have a much higher scale than
the use
so which is to say the tfidf score is
decided by the frequency but also how
informative of these words
so overall here is my step of choosing
my terms and giving them
an evaluation of tf idf score the first
one is
um
oh sorry excuse me i forgot to mention
my textbook in order to
find the terms that's related to
macroeconomics or related to tremendous
issues i want to have some baseline
where i want to have a dictionary to
find them out
the way i use this to use the textbooks
if you're interested
i use three um four different
macroeconomics sorry two different
mechatronic textbooks and three
corporate finance i will hopefully those
two
textbooks can help me
figure out what's the macro related
terms and those three corporate finance
will help me figure out what are the
important firm specific
issues
after
finding those terms i ordered them with
their tf idf score so the higher the
score it will mean
those terms more related to for example
macroeconomic issue
and every term will have a score but
they're not very useful to me i want to
choose the one that mostly that reflect
the most about macroeconomics or the
ones reflect the most about firm
specific issues therefore i choose the
top 200 terms with the highest tdtf idf
values from the result of each textbook
and i find intersection of all
textbook because remember i used two
different macro ones and three different
corporate finance ones
well i want to find the common terms
therefore i find intersection terms of
all the textbook in each category
and however sometimes we might see
in the macro
terms that i selected by the text by
human judgment is obviously related to
firm specific issues so i just simply
drop them out
and sometimes i will
just by simply checking with computer or
simply by eye browsing i can find very
common words in both macro and firm
terms obviously my assumption here is
that
firm pay
from the managerial attention to macro
and to the firm specific issues they are
totally separate they are exclusive
therefore
i choose to drop the common words in
both macro and firm term
from specific term sets and it will give
me two sets of
um terms i will show you in the next
slide
so i will end up having those two um
category of words for example
gdp monetary deficit economy
labor
phillips curves exports they are clearly
all related to macroeconomics and they
are not
related to from specific issues and
to the front side bound firm dividend or
discount creditor they are related to
from specific financing issues so i'm
relatively um satisfied with what i find
here
and after that i will use this tf idf to
generate my attention measurements
so i have
two
baseline attention measurements here i
call it attention to macroeconomics and
attention to firm
by count in order to calculating
attention to macroeconomics it's very
simple uh recall that i have
a bag of terms
thus many terms and each individual of
the term i have a tfidf score for them
to calculate attention to macroeconomics
i just
simply sum up the tfidf scores of those
terms and then i
have
the number of the terms i put them over
the number of the term macro
therefore i have i just
just thinking about it as a very simple
mass calculation you just take a average
among all those terms and you have a
measure of attention to macronomics for
each individual firm i and for each
quarter t
and i can do the same thing to match
your attention to friends using the same
methods
to generate but that's those are not the
key variables of my research my switch
is focusing on attention capacity and
attention allocation
because that that will be um whatever
the the managers will focus on when they
are doing the financial decisions
so in order to calculate attention
capacity i simply just sum up the
attention to macroeconomics and
attention to firms
the reason that it can be easily sum up
is because tfidf itself has reflects the
unit of every unit of information so
both of them are measured the
information they have the same units
that's i can simply sum them up and for
attention allocation i focus on i want
to focus on macroeconomics therefore
that's why i
use a mac economic attention over
extension capacity
so just before i show you the results of
my attention measurement i want to
briefly
remind us to thinking about what does
attention capacity mean we say we have
limited attention because everyone only
have 24 hours per day and for human
brain we're not like
the computers we can multitasking
actually we cannot multitasking we only
have one processor and the third one is
limited capacity for information
processing so sometimes we spend
the same amount of time on something but
where our efficiency will vary across
the time therefore before looking at
data i will have the assumption that
tension capacity should be very under
across the time
so here is the statistic of what i use
for the financing data um i will simply
jump here but what i want to emphasize
is that i
finally end up having a huge number of
documents
and for
3481 firms which can provide me with
enough observations to do my analysis
and the first class i will present here
is attention to
macro conditions
sorry this one is macro to attention to
macro conditions
which measures
the aggregate level across this 3 000
firms of their attention to macular
conditions and you can see there is what
we call counter cyclical pattern which
means
firstly during the 2008 um the financial
crisis the attention to macroeconomics
heightened and after the res after this
crisis it comes down but however um from
the end of 2019 to 2020 we know we have
a coveted and here we see the attention
to maconomics heightened during this
period and attention to firm condition
doesn't change that much actually we see
a slight decrease here
eventually i have my measurement of
attention capacity which have the unit
of each information times 100 because
the scale is too small it's hard to
present here
therefore we can see for managers
attention capacity from this graph we
can tell that
the attention capacity is very variant
and also it peaks during recessions
which is very easy to interpret from the
economy's mind because during reset when
the times are doing well when the
business are booming we don't worry
about the macro condition will will dip
and then that will affect my business
therefore i can choose to not to pay
well much to the macro economics or even
if i don't pay much attention to um
perceive the predict the future we know
the future won't change that much but
however during recession a lot of
uncertainties are going on i don't know
when the economy will bounce back or i
don't know what kind of policy that the
policymaker are going to give me the
physical policy or monetary policy and
once the policy announcement is out how
do i deal with this therefore we officer
will always observe a spike during
recessions
and attention allocation is a little bit
interesting he says something about um
during the last financial crisis
something fundamental is changing
which you can see from the second graph
that attention allocation to
macroeconomics have a slight moving up
through over the years
the change happens
from the 2008 financial crisis and it
never comes down after that
i want what i really want to add is this
is ongoing research i know here i only
cover a slight
area in this research but what's more
interesting is that
the managers like i hear i only
calculate to write them into macro
versus from specific however
within each macro or from specific it
can be having other subcategory
questions for example inflation or
unemployment rate or for the firm
specific it can be um
they stop establishment related or the
financial related that's those are not
captured here um those are can be very
ongoing research and what's important
what can the managers using this
information to adjust for a better
performance for the company so that's
all thank you
thank you very much for coming to pi day
to uh
i i i definitely enjoyed it it is a lot
to unravel and uh
uh i'd like to thank you and everyone
else and wish you a good day in the
rest of the
thank
conference
everyone for joining us